yeah welcome to this video and all right
let's play d4 again five-minute game
against analysts from Turkey yeah the
king's indian i recently saw a game came
on a couple of kings with this Bishop g5
line which isn't bad at all I'm re3
probably a let's go for the Benoni re
for not sure maybe if I he's got some
direct counter plane
yeah so we transposed into a modern
benoni type of position with Bishop g5
and III this is a known line it's not
not a very popular line but I don't
think it should be a bad form for white
keeping the pond III years as supposed
as opposed to having it on e4 has got
dumb has got some points at some it
offers less some counter play to black
yeah I thought this might be an idea
mmm how to continue
I'd like to expand in the center with
you for f4 and sense and moves like and
similar moves and maybe i can i can play
this this blocking move first holding
the coincide
and maybe maybe I can also play for the
move before now g5s always a bit
double-edged it's of course making sure
that this pin ism resolved but it's also
somewhat weakening not seriously
weakening it's not like ads it's
terrible or something hmm I wonder about
this right I had this idea before I mean
one or two moves to go the the idea to
play before maybe take his pawns and
maybe prepare you for covering you far
from the side
yeah this is a good move I was just
thinking about it
yeah if I take it on num mmm on d 7 it's
not grade can take with the bishop even
win a tempo on the rook and the rook
doesn't have great squares just
basically needs to return yeah but
not much choice yeah okay for I liked it
but it was good this didn't really
brought me any specific benefits yeah
f5 mm yeah this it's not not nice I was
going here to get the rook out of the
e-file so that I can prepare for but now
I see that there's this move Wow
I completely forgot about that and this
is now very very bad proly
yeah can take III pro just just III and
here i don't know why i hear spear
should be for even
yeah it looks and looks terrible for
white but it's there he's in a pin
that's not it's maybe not so easy maybe
there are some yeah he's playing good
news he's playing good moves
hmm yeah I don't want to take
don't want to take and activate all his
Holy all this stuff yes I was actually
hoping to provoke that so that I'm
threatening Bishop f2 now he's in a
somewhat awkward pin i also have bishop
a4 if he goes Bishop g6 or something
preparing look yet I've got Bishop a
form letter starts us tricky now i
blundered with giving away III but it's
not it's not so easy I think
I only hope that my week Becca rank
doesn't blow up in my face it's possible
g3 for example could be could be a moose
pawn takes this this night Neji for but
I can take with the bishop it's not
ideal I mean I wanted to set up this but
if he moves now it's no made cannot move
this
this was chicken yeah
mmm and this is covered yo
check
check
check
yeah this was lucky really lucky win I
completely forgot about this move I mean
I'm probably a bad in this position
anyway this rookie for stuff was wasn't
great oh yeah I like this move maybe it
was bad I don't know I forgot about this
and I was lucky to that this wasn't so
clear cut with the pin I mean at least
four for a human player probably wasn't
he can take now an f4 and play Queen age
for all this is good but ok we're not we
are not computers this isn't clear
though I mean for for humans at least
yeah thanks for watching